le reportage consacré à la guerre de
trappes sur les travaux de nuit qui s'y
déroulent actuellement avec des coupures
d'électricité des interventions assez
délicate qui sont menées vous pourrez le
découvrir dans l'acte us et le tout
images de la rédaction et diffusion
20h30 et 22h et puis bien sûr en
consultation libre sur notre site
internet dès à présent si vous le
souhaitez prévenir au et guérir la ceppm
semble avoir fait en tout cas un choix
marine beaury bonsoir vous êtes chef de
projet santé active pour la ceppm la
caisse primaire d'assurance maladie des
yvelines santé active s'est ouvert à
tous les assurés sociaux du régime
général s'est apprécié pour l'instant
bientôt à saint quentin en yvelines et
l'idée c'est de prévenir plutôt que de
guérir c'est bien ça c'est bien ça donc
effectivement aujourd'hui l'assurance
maladie des yvelines se lance dans cette
nouvelle offre de santé on souhaite
accompagner les assurés sur des
thématiques de santé comme la nutrition
la santé du dos ou la sauter du coeur
donc les aider au quotidien avec des
informations concrètes un sens tactique
où et comment ça fonctionne c'est très
concret ce n'est pas juste un nom il ya
derrière ça fonctionne avec trois
thématiques le coeur le dos la nutrition
voilà en fait on met en place ce qu'on
appelle du coaching on sentait donc
c'est un accompagnement personnalisé par
le biais d'entretiens individuels et
d'ateliers collectifs sur les
thématiques de la nutrition la santé du
dos et la sauter du cac donc c'est
gratuit accessible à tous et à chaque
personne en fait qu'il souhaite prendre
en main cette cette une de ces trois
thématiques en fait tout ça a été lancée
à poissy tout d'abord qu'on a vu
quelques images 450 adhérents sur pau
c'est parce qu'il faut adhérer pour
pouvoir si c'est ça on demande en fait
aux personnes qui souhaitent intégrer le
coaching sont interactifs d'adhérer ça
permet de lier aussi une relation avec
les assurés qui adhèrent on leur envoie
régulièrement l'information en santé des
dossiers d'information et on les
prévient des différents événements qu'on
peut monter parce qu'effectivement
chaque mois on essaie de mettre en place
une journée événement sur une thèmes de
prévention par exemple parler de la
semaine du goût tout à l'heure le 20
octobre prochain met en place aussi une
journée sur la thématique de la
nutrition du goût mangez cinq fruits et
légumes par jour
c'est effectivement des campagnes de
prévention qui ont été lancés qu'est ce
que ça veut dire concrètement donc on
travaille avec des diététiciennes du
département pour pour cette journée mais
pourquoi avoir décidé de mettre en place
justement santé active c'est
véritablement pour faire des économies
parce que si on fait attention à sa
santé au quotidien on tombera pas malade
c'est une évidence
voilà l'objectif premier n'est pas de
faire des économies mais effectivement
d'aider les assurés à préserver leur
capital santé
effectivement même pour l'instant on
bien aussi voilà que que l'un
effectivement va avec l'autre mais on
vraiment accompagner les assurés au
quotidien puisque aujourd'hui on a
beaucoup de personnes qui parlent de
santé mais qui s'occupent de leur santé
une fois qu'elles sont malades et nous
ce qu'on souhaite c'est que les gens
prennent en main leur santé avant ça et
que au quotidien ils puissent prendre en
main et mettre en place des habitudes de
vie qui leur permette de préserver leur
capital santé au maximum et parce que ça
va être un travail sur les mentalités en
effectivement la santé on s'en préoccupe
pas quand on va bien forcément que voilà
et les piments et donc on souhaite que
les gens aient conscience qu'ils ont
aussi eu un impact sur leur santé que
leurs habitudes de vie peuvent avoir un
impact sur leur santé et donc par des
petites choses très pratique par la mise
en place d'un équilibre alimentaire par
la mise en place de petits exercices
pour leur dos au quotidien ils peuvent
avoir une action sur sur la nutrition
leur alimentation et sur la santé de
leurs dos et vous êtes satisfaite du
résultat actuellement du dispositif sont
est active sur sur poissy
alors saint quentin en yvelines ensuite
puisque ça va ça va ouvrir également sur
50 ans donnait donc surtout ici ont
effectivement nos verts depuis le 22 mai
on a
vu plus de 1000 milles visiteurs donc
effectivement ça commence à être bien
connu sur le territoire donc on a 450
adhérents aujourd'hui on a une centaine
de personnes qui ont participé à des
ateliers qui ressorte extrêmement
satisfaits de ces ateliers en ayant
appris énormément de choses donc quand
ils sortent ils seraient 1 trèbes à
l'atelier suivant est aussi une très
bonne grande convivialité dans les
ateliers les gens se retrouve vraiment
dans les échanges qui a au cours des
ateliers donc c'est vraiment un bilan
très positif aujourd'hui alors sur saint
quentin en yvelines parce qu'il va aussi
avoir une antenne qui va s'ouvrir sur
saint quentin en yvelines après qu'on a
un projet déploiement d'autres espaces
en taxi sur le département
le 14 février prochain on ouvrira un
espace à versailles et puis donc au
premier semestre de maîtresses un autre
espace 1 à saint quentin en yvelines
aujourd'hui dans la en attendant en fait
l'ouverture de cet espace on met en
place une expérimentation avec
l'institut promotion de la santé de
trappes
en effet on met en place un programme
nutrition active avec lee ps donc tous
les ateliers qui composent le programme
nutrition actifs vont être mis en place
au sein du ps entre novembre et décembre
et ils seront accessibles donc à tous
les assurés qu'ils souhaitent sur sur la
communauté d'agglomération mêmes même au
delà donc il est possible déjà de se
renseigner auprès de la ceppm si les
gens voulaient plus d'informations dès
aujourd'hui voilà tout à fait licite de
se renseigner auprès l'espace et
interactif de poissy on va également
faire deux journées permanence au sein
du ps donc les 18 octobre et 30 octobre
prochains les jeunes à traves voilà les
gens s'y rendre que mettre en place
comme examen de prévention nous sommes
allez vous poser la question puisque
l'on parle prévention est ce que vous
faites attention à votre santé au
quotidien
voici quelques réponses c'est vrai que
le problème aujourd'hui c'est que
beaucoup de gens
ne peuvent pas aller forcément chez le
médecin ce qui était moins le quart
avant donc peut-être remettre en place
comme il y avait dans le temps des
dispensaires c'était l'idée un peu du
gouvernement actuel de remettre en place
des distances est renvoyé pour que les
gens puissent qui est une médecine de
proximité quoi personnellement je pense
qu'on y voit déjà trop souvent chez le
médecin c'est peut-être pas nécessaire
donc je sais pas si pour en rajouter de
la prévention systématiser les examens
les rendent obligatoires moi je pense
qu'on n'a pas assez de vidy dentiste
prévention donc oui les visiteurs et
dentistes gratuite fournie par la
sécurité sociale à partir d'un certain
âge faudrait certains tests obligatoires
et peut-être gratuit
parce que quand on on prévient ça coûte
moins cher que guérir
ça c'est une bonne conclusion quand on
prévient ça coûte moins cher ensuite
sont actives c'est pas obligatoire comme
dispositif on a entendu quelques unes
des personnes témoignaient les dire
qu'il faudrait rendre certains tests
certains examens obligatoires santé
active obligatoire c'est une piste aussi
oblique hasard on est vraiment sur
l'idée de rendre les assurés acteurs de
leur santé donc je pense pas qu'on
puisse aller sur une démarche jugée
porteuse d'espoir puisque l'idée c'est
qu'ils prennent en main les conseils
qu'on leur donne qui plus est appliquée
dans leur vie quotidienne donc à partir
du moment où france est impliqué at war
je pense que la présence des conseils et
l'application et devient plus compliqué
mais on a un certain nombre de
dispositifs et des campagnes de
prévention qui existent au mois
d'octobre tout le mois d'octobre on à la
campagne octobre rose
donc mon ensuite les femmes de plus de
50 ans au rebus voilà allez aller se
faire dépister donc il ya des choses qui
existent
on essaie de communiquer le plus
possible autour de ces dépistages qui
existent qui sont des dépistages
gratuits
donc voilà il ya des choses qui existent
et par le biais des espaces interactifs
qui est un espace dédié à la prévention
on essaie de faire la promotion de tous
les dispositifs de prévention qui
existent on parlait des dents aussi donc
la campagne mt dents
les bilans et les visites chez le
dentiste qui sont mises en place par les
programmes ltd on en fait également la
promotion de hausse un espace interactif
santé active à poissy dans le
département des yvelines pour l'instant
bientôt à saint quentin en yvelines et
peut-être juste très brièvement pour
conclure sur internet aussi en 2013 sur
internet aussi donc aujourd'hui on a un
site internet qui s'appelle ma santé
actifs point comme sur lequel on
retrouve le fonctionnement de la santé
active des dossiers d'information sur
les thématiques de santé
il ya aussi un petit focus puisqu'en
fait aujourd'hui le projet santé actifs
devient nationale dont il ya un certain
nombre de caisses en france qui vont
déployer ce projet et puis d'ici donc
2013 on aura un système aussi de ico
ching c'est-à-dire un coaching par
internet via le site ameli qui est le
site de l'assurance maladie
donc on pourra utiliser sa tablette par
exemple pour prendre soin de sa santé au
quotidien merci d'être venu mariembourg
il nous présentait ce projet dispositif
lancé déjà poids 600t actif pour la cpam
merci à vous est la suite du 7 8 7 avec
la page culture il sera question du
cinéma d'animation des fatals picards
également et puis à nous allons revenir
sur la journée mondiale du refus de la
misère au cours d'une page société
il est compliqué de trouver un travail
aujourd'hui c'est encore plus un casse
tête quand on se trouve en situation de
handicap un forum était organisé sur
cette question des demandeurs d'emploi
sont venus directement à la rencontre
des recruteurs à l'an passé 75 personnes
ont ainsi trouvé un travail sur le même
dispositif
reportage
des face-à-face l'informel pour
favoriser le recrutement des personnes
handicapées
pour la troisième année consécutive
handicafé a pris ses quartiers dans le
centre commercial sqy ouest à montigny
36 groupes et entreprises spécialisées
dans le bâtiment
l'aide à la personne ou encore l'intérim
ont répondu présent je leur demande de
venir c'est long des offres sinon on
leur dit écouter les offres ne
correspond pas à ce que nous avons donc
elles ne viennent pas le principe a été
initié dans l'essonne par l'adapt
association pour l'insertion sociale et
professionnelle des personnes
handicapées
on a eu cinq six candidats aujourd'hui
chez o2 on a signé la charte de la
diversité
on a sonné aussi un partenariat enfin
une convention avec l'agefiph
voilà on travaille beaucoup on a un
siège basé au nom on a une charge et de
handicap et qui travaille beaucoup sur
le handicap ça pas du tout un frein
vous avez trouvé votre bonheur alors
j'ai trouvé une candidature donc du coup
étant donné moi je suis chargé de
mission je vais rentrer à mon bureau et
je vais transférer la candidature donc
aux différents magasins que le candidat
souhaite
l'opération s'avère être un outil d aide
aux entreprises de plus de 20 salariés
qui ont depuis 2005 l'obligation
d'embaucher 6 % de personnes handicapées
dans le cas contraire elle reverse une
taxe à l'agefiph cette association de
gestion de fonds propose des services
pour faciliter l'insertion
professionnelle des personnes
handicapées accueillies pas du tout le
stress des entretiens habituel on sent
un peu avec la patiente au ca en 2011
handicapée a permis d'effectuer 45
recrutement au sein de 17 entreprises